we have a new trailer for morbius and
it's bursting with details and easter
eggs here are some small things you may
have missed in the newest upcoming
marvel film from sony entertainment at
around 1 minute 17 in the trailer the
horizon labs building briefly shows up
in the new york skyline it's not as well
known to wider audiences as a building
like oscorp but it's still pretty
important created during dan slot's run
on the amazing spider-man in 2010
horizon labs let scientists create
whatever they like as long as their
inventions better the company and
society as a whole peter quickly gets
hired by the company after managing to
turn off an experimental machine which
creates artificial vibranium it
continues to be a big part of peter's
life but he's ultimately fired by the
company before striking out on his own
to create parker industries the marvel
cinematic universe hasn't really leaned
into peter's significant scientific
prowess too much so it'll be interesting
to see how sony's spider-man universe
deals with elements like horizon labs
obviously it depends how spider-man no
way home plays out but if tom holland's
wall crawler leaves the mcu he could
always get a job at horizon labs the new
york skyline in the trailer also
features a nod to one of spider-man's
greatest foes norman osborne aka the
green goblin yes that's right the oscorp
building shows up at 1 minute 41 in the
new footage the building confirms that
norman exists somewhere in sony's
spider-man universe and by extension so
does his son harry osborne surprisingly
the company's font on the building is
the exact same one used in the amazing
spider-man franchise in that take on the
character the company is not only
responsible for the death of peter's
parents it's also where dr kirk connor
starts growing new limbs before he
transforms into the lizard and is where
max dillon becomes electro the amazing
spider-man 2 also introduces harry
osborne who eventually done the
experimental green goblin armor after
losing his mind due to a degenerative
disease the sequel even shows off
various weaponry connected to the
sinister six in an attempt to set up
various doomed sequels in the series the
morbius trailer gives us our second peek
of what seems to be michael keaton's
adrian toombs who previously made a
brief appearance in the first teaser for
the film the last we saw of tombs aka
vulture was in the post-credits scene of
spider-man homecoming the villain is now
imprisoned after the events of that
movie and looks to still be in the hands
of the police and morbius despite living
the last several years in prison tombs
knows who dr michael morbius is and
looks like he wants to work with him on
some level with vulture rumored to
appear in the upcoming spider-man no way
home film we might see more beers show
up as well as these two characters
definitely have some sort of future
together
one of the quickest but nonetheless most
noteworthy connections to previous
spider-man stories comes around the
trailer's two minute mark when morbius
looks down at a copy of a newspaper
sharp eyes will be able to make out the
paper's title in the few moments that it
remains on screen it is the daily bugle
the very same newspaper run by
professional spider-man hater jay jonah
jameson obviously jameson's
anti-superhero sentiments don't
disappear simply because sony has kept
spider-man out of the picture in this
universe the headline of this particular
issue of the bugle reveals that morbius
has been arrested as a suspect in the
case surrounding the vampire murders
however it appears that jameson is
either publishing fake news or morbius
has recently escaped because he doesn't
appear to be in police custody when he
reads the paper
it's all over town robbie gossip rumors
panic in the streets we're lucky
venom and morbius aren't the only
anti-heroes in the spider-man universe
that sony plans on giving spin-off
movies too felicia hardy otherwise known
as black cat has been the subject of a
much delayed adaptation for quite some
time that said the morbius trailer
suggests that she could be set to enter
the cinematic universe sooner rather
than later the trailer features a shot
of the daily bugle newspaper and a
headline in the top right hand corner
that reads black cat friend or foe could
this be the studio's way of telling us
that a black cat movie or tv show is on
the horizon on the other hand
considering that one of the other
headlines reads rhino on the loose zoo
hoax fools us all maybe the filmmakers
are just having fun referencing
spider-man characters marvel character
or not it really wouldn't be a vampire
movie without giving nod to one of the
most iconic fanged fiends in history
we're of course referring to
transylvania's most notorious inhabitant
count dracula not only does leto's
doctor turn to guzzling anti-hero have a
similar wardrobe to the count
pre-transformation his journey back from
his batty encounter is very reminiscent
of bram stoker's legendary vampire as
well
during his talk with tyrese gibsons
jubius lorman simon stroud it's revealed
that morbius went missing for two months
only to be found on a shipping container
that washed up near long island fans of
the classic vampire novel will recall
that dracula's reign of terror begins
after he's transported by boat from his
homeland to london killing everyone on
board before it docks judging by the
armed soldiers you meet a grizzly end in
the trailer morbius could have taken a
similar course of action and speaking of
vampire movie references the trailers
slow down cover of people are strange by
the doors is an obvious nod to joel
schumacher's cult classic vampire film
the lost boys that's not all both the
lost boys and morbius follower michael
who begins to exhibit certain
vampire-like qualities
you never grow old michael
and you'll never die
but you must feed
we can only hope that morbius features a
similar scene-stealing saxophone man
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]